مره جديده الى شبكه مراسلين المنتشرين في
المحافظات والولايات التركيه لمواكبه هذا
الحدث من اسطنبول عمر الحاج في العاصمه
انقره المعتز بالله حسن واحمد فال ولد
الدين في ازمير عمر اطلعنا على نسب
المشاركه في هذه الانتخابات بجولتها
الثانيه حتى الساعه في هذه المحافظه
المهمه محافظه اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
عاليه جدا ايضا هناك اقتضاف في هذا المركز
الذي
تعتبرها هذه هذا الحي بالتحديد هو واحد من
معاقل حزب الشعب الجمهوري في مدينه في
ولايه اسطنبول البريطانيا لما صوت له سواء
في الانتخابات البلديه او حتى في البرلمان
وفي الرئاسيات ولكن ايضا يراقبون من حزب
الشعب الجمهوري يقول ان النسبه التي حصل
عليها على حسب التنميه في هذا المركز خلال
هذه سنه مقارنه مع سنوات المنصرمه ليست
بالقليله
هنا حادثه لمشاده حصلت بين راقبين من حزب
الحركه القوميه واحد اعضاء الصندوق
مراقبين الصندوق بين من حزب الشعب
الجمهوري ما ادى الى تدخل قوات الشرطه لم
يكن هناك
شجار بالمعنى الحقيقي او ولكن كان هناك
مشاده كلاميه عنيفه ادت الى ايقاف التصويت
في في صندوق الذي كانت فيه المندوب الشعب
الجمهوري في ذلك المكان ثم بعد ذلك احل
الامر انا فقط اريد اشير كثافه التركيز
على هذه المنطقه من مراقبك كل الاطراف
اسطنبول كما تعلم جلال شاهدت تصويت الرئيس
اردوغان الذي صوتت كما هو معتاد في حي
اسكودار في ذات المنطقه التي يسكن فيها
ايضا كنا في المركز الذي صوت فيه اكرا
امام اولو رئيس وزير اسطنبول الكبرى
والمرشح لمنصب نائب الرئيس في حال فوزي
كمال في بيليه ايضا
الناخبين الاتراك الى التقدم بكثافه
لصناديق الاقتراع كذلك الامر النيران
زعيمه حزب الجيد وايضا العذر بارز في
الطاوله السداسيه كان لها تصويت في مدينه
اسطنبول كلاب مرشحي المعارضه كذا كذا
ناخبين معارضه بمعنى الندق توجه الى انقر
لمتابعه السير العمليه الانتخابيه من هناك
يعني لو كاننا نلخص احداث هذا اليوم حقيقه
اكتظاف في
مراكز الاقتراع هنا في اسطنبول في مختلف
التي
زرناها هنا وايضا نستطيع القول مره اخرى
هناك نسبه عاليه كما ذكرنا في هذا المركز
وحده في الساعه عندنا الساعه الحاديه عشر
كانت نسبه المشاركه فقط الخمسين بالمئه
والرئيس اردوغاندات وتحدثت عن نسبه عاليه
متوقعه اخيرا اشير الى ان الهيئه المجلس
الاعلى للانتخابات اشار الى احتمال اعلان
النتائج بشكل بوقت ابكر
عنه يوم امس ذلك لوجود سرعه في حسم
الاصوات طالما تحدث عن انتخابات رئاسيه
ولا نتحدث عن انتخابات رئاسيه والبرلمانيه
في ان واحد